and we gave them a sheet of paper.
And these were all novices,
and they built something that was really quite ugly --
nothing like a frog or a crane.
But then we told them, "Look, this origami really belongs to us.
You worked for us, but I'll tell you what, we'll sell it to you.
How much do you want to pay for it?"
And we measured how much they were willing to pay for it.
And we had two types of people:
We had the people who built it,
and the people who did not build it,
and just looked at it as external observers.
And what we found was that the builders thought
that these were beautiful pieces of origami --
(Laughter)
and they were willing to pay five times more for them
than the people who just evaluated them externally.
Now you could say -- if you were a builder,
do you think [you'd say], "Oh, I love this origami,
but I know that nobody else would love it?"
Or "I love this origami, and everybody else will love it as well?"
Which one of those two is correct?
Turns out the builders not only loved the origami more,
they thought that everybody would see the world in their view.
They thought everybody else would love it more as well.
In the next version, we tried to do the IKEA effect.
We tried to make it more difficult.
So for some people, we gave the same task.
For some people, we made it harder by hiding the instructions.
At the top of the sheet, we had little diagrams
of how you fold origami.
For some people, we just eliminated that.
So now this was tougher.
What happened?
Well in an objective way,
the origami now was uglier, it was more difficult.
Now when we looked at the easy origami, we saw the same thing --
builders loved it more, evaluators loved it less.
When you looked at the hard instructions,
the effect was larger.
Why?
Because now the builders loved it even more.
(Laughter)
They put all this extra effort into it.
And evaluators?
They loved it even less.
Because in reality, it was even uglier than the first version.
(Laughter)
Of course, this tells you something about how we evaluate things.
Now think about kids.
Imagine I asked you, "How much would you sell your kids for?"
Your memories and associations and so on.
Most people would say for a lot, a lot of money.
(Laughter)
On good days.
But imagine this was slightly different.
Imagine if you did not have your kids.
And one day you went to the park and you met some kids.
They were just like your kids,
and you played with them for a few hours,
and when you were about to leave, the parents said, "Hey, by the way,
just before you leave, if you're interested, they're for sale."
(Laughter)
How much would you pay for them now?
Most people say not that much.
And this is because our kids are so valuable,
not just because of who they are,
but because of us,
because they are so connected to us,
and because of the time and connection.
By the way, if you think IKEA instructions are not good,
what about the instructions that come with kids, those are really tough.
(Laughter)
By the way, these are my kids, which, of course, are wonderful and so on.
Which comes to tell you one more thing,
which is, much like our builders,
when they look at the creature of their creation,
we don't see that other people don't see things our way.
Let me say one last comment.
If you think about Adam Smith versus Karl Marx,
Adam Smith had a very important notion of efficiency.
He gave an example of a pin factory.
He said pins have 12 different steps,
and if one person does all 12 steps, production is very low.
But if you get one person to do step one,
and one person to do step two and step three and so on,
production can increase tremendously.
And indeed, this is a great example,
and the reason for the Industrial Revolution and efficiency.
Karl Marx, on the other hand,
said that the alienation of labor is incredibly important
in how people think about the connection to what they are doing.
And if you do all 12 steps, you care about the pin.
But if you do one step every time, maybe you don't care as much.
I think that in the Industrial Revolution,
Adam Smith was more correct than Karl Marx.
But the reality is that we've switched,
and now we're in the knowledge economy.
You can ask yourself, what happens in a knowledge economy?
Is efficiency still more important than meaning?
I think the answer is no.
I think that as we move to situations
in which people have to decide on their own
about how much effort, attention, caring, how connected they feel to it,
are they thinking about labor on the way to work,
and in the shower and so on,
all of a sudden Marx has more things to say to us.
So when we think about labor,
we usually think about motivation and payment as the same thing,
but the reality is that we should probably add all kinds of things to it --
meaning, creation, challenges, ownership, identity, pride, etc.
The good news is that if we added all of those components
and thought about them --
how do we create our own meaning, pride, motivation,
and how do we do it in our workplace,
and for the employees --
I think we could get people to be both more productive and happier.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)